Joe Biden has departed for Israel the US
is surging thousands of troops into the
region we're learning that several
thousand more are currently on their way
and they are preparing 2,000 more for
potential deployment currently it is
being reported by The Washington Post
that 19,000 Personnel are in the region
already with 2,000 more preparing to go
we are also learning that the US Embassy
and Israeli Embassy are being I don't
know what the right word is for this
besieged I don't want to call it a
protest it's not a protest it's else
they've tried to storm the Israeli
Embassy already in Jordan there's
reporting that in Beirut there is some
kind of attack on the US Embassy but
that may be incorrect we're getting a
lot of conflicting reports right now it
seems like what we can say more
definitively is that there was an
attempt to storm the Israeli Embassy in
Jordan the meeting between Joe Biden and
jordanan the Jordanian government has
been cancelled and there is a tremendous
fear among many uh commentators and
political personalities that Joe Biden
is in serious danger going into the
region right now